after the ruling campaigners spoke about
its impact on their families
as a mother of six uh five atypical
children and one with down syndrome i
love them all the same and i value them
all the same and obviously i don't my
child growing up in a world where she's
gonna be treated any less different to
anybody else she's a human she should
have the same rights and it is
discrimination and is wrong i just hope
they take it all the way as far as they
can and win
well our correspondent ali fortescue
joins me now from outside the high court
and ali there are powerful and emotional
arguments on both sides of this debate
aren't there
really strong feelings on both sides of
this debate and this was a landmark test
case a case that could have changed
abortion law in this country as we know
it heidi carter you mentioned there
she's 26 year old with down syndrome she
wanted to change the law that allows
babies with severe fetal abnormalities
disabilities including down syndrome to
be aborted right up until the point of
birth and normally the restriction is 24
weeks
for women to have an abortion so she
wanted to change the rules she says that
the law as it stands is downright
discriminatory and makes her feel like
her life isn't valued in the same way as
other unborn babies have a listen to
what she had to say outside court after
that judgment was delivered
i'm really upset not to win
but the fight is not over
the judges might not think it
discriminates against me the government
might not
think
you're okay
it's just against me but i'm telling you
that i do feel disagreed against
and the virgin doesn't change how i as
thousands of
community feel
we face discrimination every day in
schools
in the workplace
and in the society
thanks to the verdict the duties have a
power discrimination in the womb too
this is a very sad day but i will keep
on fighting
so very strong feelings tears highly
emotional statements made outside court
including um from moya lee wilson who's
someone who we've also spoken to a lot
she's a mother of a two-year-old son
aiden who has down syndrome she says she
has two children one who has down
syndrome one who doesn't she values them
and loves them both equally and what she
wants to see is the law changed to value
them equally as well and she says she
will continue fighting and appeal this
decision she is one of those uh three
claimants that's brought this case but
as you say really strong feelings on
both sides of this this is about the
balance between a woman's right to
choose and the rights of unborn children
with disabilities and we've spoken to
just now to the british pregnancy
advisory service and they say these are
decisions that women do not take lightly
and these are decisions that need to be
given the time and space and that often
women don't know the exact diagnosis
until after 24 weeks and they need to
understand the context and the
implication that having a child with
disabilities could mean for their lives
and they say that any change to the law
as it stands would be a step in the
wrong direction so strong feelings on
both sides of this but as i say um those
claimants three claimants have vowed to
appeal the decision and change the law
that they say discriminates against
people with disabilities
ali thank you very much